Thank you very much, Mr.
President.
No, it was
it was one year ago this week,
and we spoke on the telephone.
Mr. President.
It was very late in night in Washington.
Early in the morning here in Kiev.
Russian planes were in
the air
and tanks were rolling
across your border.
You told me
that you could hear the explosions
in the background.
I'll never forget that
and the world was about to change.
I remember it vividly
because I asked to I asked you next.
I asked you what is there, Mr.
President,
what can I do for you?
How can I be of help?
And I know they remember what you said
to me, what you said, and I quote,
gather the leaders of the world,
ask them
to support Ukraine.
Gather the leaders of the world
and ask them to support Ukraine.
And you said you didn't know
when we would be able to speak again
that dark night
one year ago,
the world was literally at the time
bracing for the fall in Kyiv.
Seems like a lot longer ago than a year.
But think back to that year,
perhaps even the end of Ukraine.
You know,
one year later, Kyiv stands
and Ukraine stands.
Democracy stands
The Americans stand with you
and the world stands with you.
Kyiv has captured a part of my heart,
I must say,
I've come here six times
as vice president, once as president,
and in 2009 as vice president.
And I first came here,
then back in 20, 14.
I came three times in the aftermath of
the revolution of dignity.
And I
again came in 2015
to address the Rada
about the work of building
a strong democracy
and I came in 2017
just before I left office
as Vice President
I knew I'd be back,
but I wanted to be sure,
even though the election were over,
Barack and I were out of office.
I decided to make one more trip
before the next president was sworn in
to Kyiv.
So President Zelensky you deeply honor me
here in key with you today
to meet with your military,
your intelligence,
folks, your diplomatic teams,
community leaders who have stepped up
and helped their country
in their hour of need is astounding.
Who stood up?
Everybody.
Women,
young children.
Try to do some of this, trying to
do something
pulling people out of apartments
have been shelled.
And literally,
that I think, is a war crimes.
It's astounding
in the whole world.
The whole world sees it
and looks at it.
This is the largest land war in Europe
in three quarters of a century.
And you're succeeding
against all and every expectation
except your own.
We have every confidence
that you're going
to continue to prevail and
you know,
from the moment I
first received
an intelligence report in the fall,
about a year ago,
we were focused on determining
how do we rally the rest of the world.
How do I help you with the promise
you asked me to make, to rally the world?
Well,
how do you succeed?
How do you get a world to respond?
To a prosperous
economy, confident democracy,
a secure and independent state?
When united Americans
of all political backgrounds decided
they would step up
American people, no matters.
Unchecked aggression
is a threat to all of us.
We build a coalition of nations
from the Atlantic to the Pacific
NATO's
to the land, the Atlantic,
Japan and the Pacific.
I mean, across the across the world.
The number of nations that have over 50
help Ukraine defend itself.
Unprecedented military,
economic and humanitarian support.
We united the leading economies
of the world to impose unprecedented cost
that are squeezing Russia's
economic lifelines.
Together,
we've committed nearly 700 tanks
and thousands of armored vehicles,
1000 artillery systems,
more than 2 million rounds
of artillery ammunition,
more than 50 advanced
launch rocket systems
and AI ship and air defense systems.
All defend you to defend Ukraine.
And that doesn't count
the other half a billion dollars.
We're going to be
we're announcing with you today
and tomorrow.
That's going to be coming your way.
And that's
just the United States in this piece.
And just today,
that announcement includes
artillery ammunition
for high marks and Howitzers,
more javelins and the armor systems,
air surveillance radars to help protect
Ukrainian people from aerial bombardment.
Later this week,
we will announce additional sanctions
against elites and companies
that are trying to evade sanctions
and backfill Russia's war machine.
And thanks to bipartisan support
in Congress
this week, we're delivering billions
in direct budgetary support,
billions in direct budgetary support,
which the government
can put to use immediately
to help provide for basic
services of citizens.
The cost that Ukraine has had
to bear has been extraordinarily high,
and the sacrifices
have been far too great.
They've been met with them
and far too great.
We mourn alongside the families of those
who've been lost to the brutal
and unjust war.
We know that there will be very difficult
days and weeks and years ahead.
But Russia's aim
was to wipe Ukraine off the map
Putin's war conquest
is failing
Russia's military has lost
half its territory once occupied
young town, and Russians
are fleeing by the tens of thousands
not wanting to come back to Russia.
Not from
not just fleeing from the military,
fleeing from Russia itself.
Because they see
no future in their country.
Russia's economy
is now a backwater,
isolated, is struggling
Putin thought Ukraine was weak
and the West was divided.
As you know, Mr.
President,
I said to you in the beginning,
he's counting on us
not sticking together.
He was counting on an inability
to keep NATO's united
Is counting on us
not to be able to bring in others
on the side of Ukraine.
He thought he could outlast us.
I don't think he's thinking that
right now.
God knows what he's thinking.
I don't think he's thinking that
he's just been plain wrong.
Plain wrong.
And one year later,
the evidence is right here in this room.
We stand here together.
Mr.
President,
I'm delighted to be able
to repay your visit to our country
in Washington.
Not long ago,
you told us,
you told the Congress,
quote, We have no fear
nor should anyone in the world have it.
And of, quote,
you and all Ukrainians.
Mr.
President, remind the world
every single day
what the meaning of the word courage is.
From all sectors, your economy,
all walks of life.
It's astounding.
Astounding
Remind us of freedom
is priceless.
It's worth fighting for,
for as long as it takes.
And that's how long we're going to be
with you, Mr. President.
For as long as it takes.
We'll do it. Thank you.